SCP-035 Vs SCP-096.
The Possessive Mask Vs The Shy Guy, two forces
of terrifying malice and destruction.
But who would win?
SCP-096 enters a rage state when anyone sees
its face, being both indestructible and unstoppable
under these conditions.
However, the real question is whether SCP-035
really sees, meaning it may not activate 096’s
aggression at all.
SCP-035 is a dangerous, mind-controlling mask
with evil intentions that slowly melts its
hosts.
However, we would argue that these two might
be a match made in Hell: SCP-096 may love
having its face covered by a mask, and 035
would love having an indestructible body.
If we put these two up against each other,
we’d be the ones in trouble.